[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos Experts
le rendez-vous c'est tous les soirs 18h
ou 22h sur Public Sénat 90 minutes et
deux débats pour commencer l'actualité
et ces manifestations en Chine dans la
plus grande usine mondiale de
fabrication d'iPhone contre la politique
zéro covid de ksijin ping une stratégie
sanitaire qui est dénoncée par l'OMS
quand nous parlons de stratégie zéro
covid nous ne pensons pas que c'est
soutenable
où il donne considérant le comportement
du virus à l'heure actuelle et celui que
nous prévoyons dans le futur
le président chinois mène son pays dans
l'impasse le chômage grimpe la
croissance essouffle la population au
grogne peut-on assister à une révolte
massive quelles sont les conséquences
des confinements sur l'économie mondiale
réponse juste après ces titres et puis
dans 45 minutes c'est un débat de
société que je vous propose début
décembre ce sera la fin du tirage au
sort des citoyens qui participeront à la
Convention sur la fin de vie on se
demandera s'il faut modifier la loi
Claes Leonetti faut-il s'inspirer de nos
voisins belges ou espagnols qui
autorisent le tanazi ne faut-il pas
plutôt et prioritairement donné au
service de soins palliatifs les moyens
d'accompagner correctement les malades
ont confronte les idées et les
propositions de nos invités tout à
l'heure mais d'abord donc ce vent de
révolte qui souffre qui souffle pardon
sur une Chine bâillonnée par la
politique zéro covid Audrey Vittaz
ces images sont censurées sur les
réseaux sociaux chinois des
affrontements violents extrêmement rares
entre des centaines d'ouvriers de la
plus grosse usine d'iPhone au monde et
les policiers en tenue blanche de
protection les ouvriers de foxconnes
principales sous-traitant d'Apple tente
de fuir leur usine confinées
transformées en enfer sanitaire depuis
plus d'un mois après la détection de cas
de covid la répression est extrêmement
violente cet homme est roué de coup
jusqu'au sang
cet homme est gravement blessé il saigne
tellement preuve de l'embarras du
pouvoir deux jours après le début des
émeutes les autorités affirment ne rien
savoir
je ne suis pas au courant de la
situation que vous avez évoquée d'après
les ouvriers les émeutes ont débuté
contre les primes promises pour rester
dans l'usine et maintenir les cadences
son passé de 400 à 4 euros mais elles
sont aussi le symbole de la lassitude de
la population après plus de trois ans de
pandémie et au moment où la Chine
renforce encore son protocole
anti-covide elle confine 6 millions de
personnes quand le reste du monde semble
apprendre à vivre avec le virus
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce débat consacré à la
Chine à cette politique zéro covid Marie
Holtzman bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sinologue présidente de l'association
Solidarité Chine Jean-Philippe déjà
bonsoir et bienvenue directeur de
recherche et meilleures CNRS spécialisé
dans la vie politique chinoise
Pierre-Antoine Denet bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi journaliste à asialiste
auteur de ce livre le dossier chinois
portrait d'un pays au bord de l'abîme
publié aux éditions du Cherche Midi je
signale aussi vous êtes ancien rédacteur
en chef de l'Agence France Presse je
vais commencer par on va rebondir sur ce
reportage donc dans cette
usine géante on est chez un
sous-traitant d'Apple Marie Holtzman
est-ce qu'on déjà il y a une question
difficile est-ce qu'on sait ce qui s'y
passe c'est vous vous avez beaucoup
d'antenne qui vous font remonter des
informations de depuis la Chine des gens
qui scrutent le internet là-bas est-ce
qu'on sait ce qui se passe dans cette
usine
on sait assez bien oui oui les
informations remontent quand même
bon il y a plusieurs scénarios parce que
c'est quand même une usine qui emploie
200 000 ouvriers donc c'est pas juste
une chose mais entre autres on a fait
appel à des ouvriers qui sont venus d'un
peu partout en Chine en leur proposant
une somme assez faramineuse de 25000
yens et puis on leur a dit vous venez
travailler de moi et puis une fois
qu'ils sont arrivés on leur a dit ah bah
finalement non il faudrait que vous
travaillez de moi et puis au bout des
deux autres mois on vous donnera la
prime qu'on vous a promise donc ça c'est
une chose il y a eu aussi un appel à la
patriotisme donc on a appelé des petits
fonctionnaires du Parti communiste
chinois qui sont tout autour de la ville
de Jon Jones dans des bourgades on leur
a dit il y a plus d'ouvriers ils sont
plus là c'est la catastrophe on ne peut
pas honorer nos commandes il faut que
vous veniez vite et puis on leur a dit
bien sûr il y a comme il y a des malades
à l'intérieur de l'usine on vous mettra
pas dans l'usine et vous serez logés et
puis etc et puis ils sont arrivés dans
l'usine et puis évidemment il devait
avoir une formation donc c'est les
anciens ouvriers qui sont venus et puis
il y avait pas de logement en dehors de
l'usine pour eux donc ils ont dit mais
il y a des malades du covid nous vous
mettez là ah mais non monsieur là sont
pas malade donc le pouvoir est en train
de se prendre les pieds dans son propre
mensonge parce que il confine les gens
c'est très pratique ils gardent les
ouvriers alors là c'est littéralement 24
heures sur 24 dans l'usine alors combien
d'heures ils travaillent à ce rythme là
j'en sais rien peut-être 18h par jour ça
j'ai pas d'informations mais on comprend
que au bout d'un certain temps les
ouvriers
perdent leur calme quoi et enfin mais ça
c'est les histoires fourmis alors
justement il y a cette évidemment vous
l'avez évoqué cette question du mensonge
on y reviendra dans ce dans ce débat
Jean-Philippe Béjaïa c'est pas la
première fois d'ailleurs que dans cette
usine il y a eu des mouvements de
révolte manifestation a commencé
effectivement au début du mois d'octobre
et donc la situation est un peu
correspond à ce que venez de dire Marie
mais c'est une vieille histoire Foxton
quand elle était à shanjan donc à la
frontière de Hong Kong c'était les
suicides c'est-à-dire que les gens se
suicidaient parce que les conditions de
travail étaient étaient absolument
épouvantables en fait il faut quand même
dire une chose c'est que il faut que je
connais c'est une c'est une marque
taïwanaise c'est donc la plus grande
usine d'iPhone du monde qui est en Chine
est une usine taïwanaise ce qui dit
quelque chose aussi sur les rapports
entre Taïwan et la Chine donc si vous
voulez oui de la situation est vraiment
atroce au fond ce qui est étonnant c'est
que ça se soit pas produit plutôt
que cette cocotte-minute en quelque
sorte et pas c'est-à-dire que la
situation est très très difficile alors
aujourd'hui le pouvoir vient
apple vient de dire qu'ils vont donner
les primes justement contrairement à ce
qu'ils avaient dit et puis le pouvoir a
confiné John Joe comme ça c'est beaucoup
plus tranquille donc toute la ville
toute la ville alors plusieurs de en
dehors de de Fox et si vous voulez on
voit bien quand même un peu comme le les
la politique anticoride et aussi
pratique pour renforcer le contrôle sur
l'ensemble de la société quand il y a
quelque chose si vous êtes mécontent
votre téléphone fait chacun un téléphone
à une application qui dit si vous êtes
contagieux ou pas quand vous êtes
mécontent et qu'on sait votre
application passe au rouge vous êtes
symptomatique mais vous pouvez pas
sortir vous pouvez pas aller au magasin
vous pouvez rien faire donc c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est un peu gênant
on s'attendait à une un relâchement des
contrôles ça avait été plus ou moins
annoncé il y a une décision en 20 points
qui devrait permettre de relâcher
quelque part or ce qui se passe c'est
que personne n'ose parce qu'il faut bien
voir que le système aujourd'hui c'est
que si j'ai une fille contre tous c'est
le grand chef et il y a une commission
de contrôle de la discipline qui est
omniprésente les cadres locaux ont très
peur alors donc on leur dit oui on va
pouvoir un peu rel les contrats mais si
jamais il y a une explosion de covid et
ils ont très peur on leur dira tu es
responsable aujourd'hui le contrôle du
covid fait partie de l'évaluation pardon
ne sont pas vaccinés les salariés alors
écoutez ils sont peut-être vaccinés mais
vous savez que le vaccins chinois et pas
extrêmement efficace mais de toute façon
il y a c'est pas qu'il y a des morts il
y a simplement des cas quand vous êtes
vacciné vous pouvez très bien attraper
le covid ça veut pas dire mais la
politique c'est zéro covid si j'ai une
fille a dit ça a marché il y a 3 ans
donc c'est la politique qu'on continue
voilà donc on est dans une obstination
alors c'est évidemment difficile à
évaluer Pierre Antoine Denay dans un
pays où si gigantesque si peuplé que la
Chine mais est-ce que ça traduit une
sorte de ras-le-bol général ou ou est-ce
qu'on peut pas dire ça ce soir si on
peut le dire parce qu'en fait là le
covid et la gestion catastrophique de la
pandémie par les autorité chinoise le
fait émerger tous ces
dans la rue et ailleurs mais
la colère d'une partie de la population
chinoise elle existe depuis des années
simplement quand il se passe quelque
chose il y a pendant 10 minutes un quart
d'heure quelque chose sur les réseaux
sociaux puis ensuite les petites mains
du pouvoir ils fassent tout ça donc si
vite que ça tient un quart d'heure c'est
très rapide extrêmement rapide parce que
ils sont très nombreux ceux qui prennent
soin justement de d'exercer la censure
surtout les réseaux sociaux puis d'autre
part vous savez
là aussi les moyens de contrôle
Jean-Philippe vient de le dire sont
extrêmement puissants les gens ont peur
et la peur elle est omniprésente et bien
sûr que les frustrations sont absolument
énormes elles se sont cristallisées déjà
à Shanghai il y a quelques mois on a eu
des scènes mais absolument hallucinantes
on voyait des des familles de chinois
sur leur balcon qui criaient leur
désespoir qui disait nous avons faim et
qui s'en prenait aux partis communiste
chinois de façon explicite ça ne s'était
jamais vu ça c'est un grand
supplémentaire dans la révolte le Louis
fait de nommer le Parti communiste
chinois c'est ça et ben oui même
et récemment un geste de désespoir à
Pékin un jeune chinois a accroché deux
grandes banderoles qui disait mais de
façon très simple nous voulons des
élections nous voulons la dignité nous
voulons manger nous voulons pas d'un
potentat ah bah si zimping c'était dit
bien évidemment ces banderolles ont été
arracher très très peu de temps après
mais malgré tout elles aient ont été vus
parce que même si ça ne reste qu'un
quart d'heure sur les réseaux sociaux
ceux qui les ont vu ensuite les
répercutes donc ça fait quand même boule
de neige mais ceci étant dit on peut
malgré tout dire que une grande partie à
population ne s'est pas vraiment alors
justement cette liberté
d'informer cette capacité à s'informer
c'est évidemment très très compliqué
pour ne pas dire quasi impossible en
Chine je vous propose une démonstration
avec l'histoire d'un homme qui est entré
dans la ville de one on va faire un
retour en arrière on est en avril 2020
il prend de des risques importants pour
s'entretenir avec des proches des
victimes du covid et des habitants qui
sont confrontés dans la ville au
pénuries de nourriture et de soins il en
est il en sort un livre et forcément
depuis il vit en exil son témoignage
tout belles choses après la publication
de mon livre mon éditeur c'est inquiété
du fait que je courais un grand danger
si je restais en Chine et m'a donc
exhorté à quitter la Chine immédiatement
ce livre a été écrit en secret à chaque
fois que je terminais un chapitre j'ai
envoyé le fichier à l'aide d'un logiciel
de cryptage à mes amis à l'étranger puis
je le supprimais de mon ordinateur
alors je me rends compte que enfin c'est
parce que vous l'avez dit que j'ai
oublié de présenter Laetitia Krupa qui
est évidemment à mes côtés évidemment
éditorious petit non mais il y a un
petit peu de fatigue ce soir il y a un
petit peu de fatigue j'en suis vraiment
désolé Marie Holtzman quand vous voyez
ces images donc finalement un homme qui
a eu le courage de vouloir témoigner et
qui qui devait le faire forcément en
sécurisant ses envois et qui a dû
quitter le pays très très vite ça c'est
pas très étonnant de la part du régime
chinois mais est-ce que cette stratégie
zéro covid donc parler les uns et les
autres
c'est pas en train de renforcer aussi ce
système répressifaire la stratégie zéro
coude elle arrange aussi le pouvoir on
peut dire évidemment évidemment c'est un
contrôle absolu vous avez votre petit
policier là dans votre téléphone à
chaque instant à chaque instant mais
quoi que vous fassiez quel que soit la
personne à laquelle vous vous adressez
donc c'est absolument terrifiant
c'est une question que se pose des amis
chinois ici qui me disent mais si on
rentre en Chine et qu'on n'a pas de
téléphone comment ça se passe c'est pas
compliqué il peut rien faire ils peuvent
pas monter dans le bus ils peuvent pas
prendre le train il peut pas entrer dans
un restaurant donc c'est vide quel que
soit les régions c'est pas on parle pas
seulement des grandes villes quand on
décrit cette si on est au fin fond de la
campagne etc non j'imagine qu'on peut
aller prendre une soupe chez les paysans
mais le problème c'est qu'il faut y
arriver au fin fond de la campagne et
même là je suis pas sûr que ce soit
possible est-ce que ça veut dire
Jean-Phi Béja que enfin est-ce que cet
argument du covid qui permet à la
répression de de s'exprimer encore mieux
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles qui dit pin de l'abandonne
pas
on pourrait le croire en tout cas d'une
part c'est parce que ça a marché dans un
premier temps c'est vrai qu'on était
tous
submergé par le virus beaucoup de morts
et là la Chine a vu très peu de mort ça
a été très efficace donc puisque ça a
été très efficace et ben voilà on va
continuer jusqu'au bout c'est la
stratégie et maintenant ça c'était il y
a 3 ans et ça fait rien le problème vous
comprenez pas la réalité en s'en fiche
l'important c'est que
on s'est trompé à un moment quoi
ne se trompe pas il vient d'être renommé
pour pour un troisième mandat il se
trompe pas il a été nommé parce que
justement il a la ligne juste donc sa
ligne est juste donc dans ces conditions
on peut rien changer je voulais juste
revenir sur ce que disait le mouvement
de fête soin vous en fait c'est pas non
plus n'importe qui c'est quelqu'un qui
depuis très très longtemps est un
journaliste critique et qui allait y
venait entre Hong Kong et entre Hong
Kong et la Chine donc il a une grande
habitude mais si vous voulez la
difficulté qu'il y a les mécontents sont
très nombreux mais ce qui se passe
est-ce que le Parti communiste est
capable de faire et ça depuis
l'ambassade du 4 juin 1989 c'est
d'empêcher les gens de prendre contact
entre eux c'est la hantise du Parti
communiste c'est ce qu'on appelle le
tchoin nier c'est à dire que les gens se
rencontrent et puis s'organiser pour
poser un défi au parti et ça on à la
limite si vous restez chez vous et que
vous dites beaucoup de mal de ces
Jinping à l'intérieur de votre maison
tout le monde s'en fiche mais si vous
sortez dans la rue mais que vous allez
avec deux ou trois copains si je
téléphone à Marie et je lui dis tiens on
va se retrouver à tienne elle-même pour
dire du mal de Sidi meking là vous allez
retrouver vous allez vous retrouver en
prison donc
la grande force de personnes quoi
presque il y a pas besoin de réunir un
millier de personnes pour être déjà un
joli but des gens qu'aujourd'hui le
contrôle les moyens de contrôle sont
elles que vous pouvez savoir
très rapidement grâce aux caméras de
surveillance grâce aux applications le
covid vous empêche de sortir vous pouvez
pas sortir
le pays alors il y a des gens qui
quittent le pays vous êtes La
Grande-Motte c'est maintenant c'est ce
qu'on appelle le run en fait en Chine
donc mais il faut avoir les moyens pour
quitter le pays aujourd'hui c'est
extrême c'est extrêmement cher pour
sortir si vous voulez venir de Pékin
aujourd'hui à à Paris c'est 5000 euros
et vous avez besoin d'une raison donc
beaucoup de gens s'inquiètent justement
du fait que peut-être on pourra plus
quitter la Chine aussi facilement on
pourra plus aller voyager autre beaucoup
de gens il y a plus de tourisme alors il
y a plutôt à cause du covid mais les
gens se disent mais est-ce qu'un jour on
va pouvoir repartir revoyager et c'est
pas évident et je veux dire que le
discours de cgping sur ce sujet et pas
clair on sait pas du tout jusqu'où va
aller contrôle et c'est donc quelque
chose qui est alors le mécontentement
est fréquent et vous avez des gens qui
effectivement ils sont ils sont
courageux les gens de les gens de Foxton
ou les autres qui a Shanghai faisaient
des castéraires mais il est impossible
de de concentrer il y a pas
d'organisation il faut que vous avez
200000 ouvriers c'est un vrai semblable
il y a 200000 ouvriers il y a eu tous
ces problèmes qui sont posés mais il y a
pas de vous savez il y a des gens qui a
Hong Kong observent de très près la
création d'organisation non
gouvernementale de défense des ouvriers
jusqu'à 2012 jusqu'à 2015 plus
exactement il y en avait et donc il y
avait des des mouvements collectifs là
non là c'est tout à fait spontané sur
200 000 ouvriers il y a pas eu
d'organisation il y a rien et donc on a
donné on a donné satisfaction du point
de vue des primes est-ce que j'entendais
dire moi c'est que aujourd'hui le calme
est revenu à Foxconn et donc ça signifie
Pierre-Antoine Denet que on a on a tous
en tête mais c'est la l'actualité qui
fait ça les manifestations en Iran
depuis deux mois un phénomène à
iranienne et de pays sont évidemment pas
comparables etc mais c'est difficile à
imaginer en Chine avec cette répression
et ce contrôle permanent si on compare
les deux pays je veux dire une chose qui
est très claire c'est que le peuple
iranien on s'est beaucoup plus sur ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de l'EP de
leur pays que les Chinois dans leur pays
eux-mêmes ça n'a rien à voir
le système policier est tel comme comme
il a été dit que les libertés sont
supprimées alors chez soi effectivement
on peut dire à peu près ce qu'on veut
quoique mais son voisin et à la
dénonciation et on en vient parfois
d'ailleurs bon un peu comme la
révolution culturelle ou les proches se
dénoncent mais bon ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que c'est quand même un
étrange retour de balancier et parce que
on a trouvé les premiers cas de covid à
urane fin 2019 et là aujourd'hui le seul
pays où la pandémie reprend à toute
vitesse c'est la Chine alors c'est vrai
que rapporter à la population le nombre
de cas n'est pas très important mais
quand même il faut savoir une chose
c'est que quelque part ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est le prix à payer d'une
erreur de la direction chinoise parce
que un les vaccinations
ont concernait essentiellement les
personnes âgées dans les campagnes ou
finalement ce n'est pas vraiment il y
avait pas de raison d'être d'autre part
comme il a été dit les deux vaccins
sinopharm et synovaques ont une
efficacité prouvé d'à peu près 50% ou
les ARN messagers sont loin devant
donc voilà on en arrive à une situation
non pas explosive parce qu'on l'a dit ça
ne l'a pas dégénéré beaucoup mais avec
des conséquences funestes pour
l'économie chinoise funeste pour
l'emploi funeste également pour les
investissements étrangers là tout
concorde on le voit bien les experts
sont à peu près unanimes pour dire que
loin de l'objectif officiel de 5 et demi
pour cent de croissance du PIB en 2022
si on arrive à 3% ça sera déjà bien beau
ce qui est très bas pour pour la Chine
alors les conséquences c'est par exemple
aujourd'hui 20% de taux de chômage chez
les jeunes mais c'est considérable parce
que ça aussi c'est du jamais mais je
voudrais juste rajouter une chose c'est
que là aussi les conséquences sont
funestes sur le plan des investissements
aujourd'hui des dizaines et des dizaines
sinon des centaines de groupes étrangers
font leurs valises alors on y reviendra
sur les conséquences économiques un peu
plus tard dans ce débat mais puisqu'on
parle de contrôle de l'information
Laetitia je voudrais qu'on vienne
ensemble sur les relations à géométrie
variable entre l'OMS l'Organisation
Mondiale de la de la santé et la Chine
depuis le début de cette pandémie on
peut dire que l'OMS est passé de du
statut d'amis à ennemi en quelque sorte
oui c'est un tout petit peu
c'est vrai que c'est une façon de
clarifier un peu cette relation ambiguë
que l'OMS a eu avec la Chine depuis le
début c'est un peu comme si on partait
de la la base Donald Trump rappelez-vous
il disait que l'OMS était la marionnette
de la Chine il a des claqué la porte de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé et
puis Joe Biden finalement a fait
réintégrer les États-Unis il s'agit pas
d'un commentaire de comptoir ou d'une
analyse qui qui serait inspirée très
inspiré par les États-Unis non il y a un
groupe d'experts indépendants qui a
enquêté qui a enquêté sur ses rapports
entre l'OMS et la Chine et qui a conclu
en effet à des errances de l'OMS
notamment au début à ces hésitations à
déclarer l'urgence sanitaire mondiale
elle a quand même mis un mois à le faire
alors qu'elle m'aime avait anticipé
c'est ça qui est vraiment surprenant
elle avait anticipé dans ces travaux de
prospective elle avait anticipé un
scénario de coronavirus sous le terme de
maladies X et donc il y a aussi cette
mission d'enquête de l'OMS on est en
janvier 2021 qui a été critiqué oui
alors j'ai cité l'objectif de la mission
et ce sont les mots de l'OMS établir une
évaluation honnête de la gestion de la
crise est tirée des leçons et pour
l'avenir or il n'y a eu aucune
investigation menée toutes les données
sont passées par le filtre d'abord des
Chinois la Chine a déterminé le planning
précis de la mission et surtout le
rapport de l'OMS c'est abstenu de toute
conclusion susceptible d'un disposer pk
à ce jour en fait toutes les hypothèses
restent encore ouvertes les critiques
finalement les plus acerbes et puis
c'est les analystes remarque la Chine a
été soucieuse finalement de de combattre
contre tout reproche qui seraient liés à
sa gestion de cette crise sanitaire et
elle a constamment mené en bateau
finalement l'agence onusienne il faut
reconnaître aussi que c'est pas simple
d'enquêter dans un pays où il faut aussi
avoir la coopération
et en mai dernier on peut considérer que
le vent en quelque sorte tourné l'OMS
critique publiquement la politique zéro
covid de la Chine oui je vous propose
d'écouter le secrétaire général de l'OMS
jusqu'à la considéré par les Chinois
comme un homme de confiance
toutes ces actions comme nous le
répétons depuis le début doivent être
prises dans le respect des individus et
des droits de l'homme nous avons
toujours affirmé au sein de l'OMS que
nous devions trouver un équilibre entre
les mesures sanitaires et leur impact
sur la société et sur l'économie ce qui
n'est pas toujours facile à faire voilà
on est en mer on mai dernier les droits
de l'homme sont enfin évoqués c'est la
première fois que
secrétaire général de l'OMS assez mot et
bien sûr cette déclaration vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure a été immédiatement
censurée dans tous les médias sur tous
les réseaux sociaux effacés et le
lendemain la Chine a répondu via le
porte-parole du ministère des Affaires
étrangères écoutez
nous espérons que les personnes
concernées pourront adopter un point de
vue objectif et rationnel sur les
politiques chinoises de prévention et de
contrôle des épidémies
et s'abstenir de faire des remarques qui
responsables
de sourd et puis réponse à la chinoise
le vent a donc tourné vous avez raison
Thomas à l'OMS semble s'être positionné
dans le camp des Occidentaux dominés par
les États-Unis largement critiques du
verrouillage de la Chine qui empêche
finalement tout anticipation est mise en
place d'un dispositif de prévention en
cas de nouvelles pandémie parce que
c'est ça le risque c'est les autres
pandémies à venir avec ce verrouillage
de la Chine c'est impossible d'anticiper
Jean-Philippe Béja j'ai posé une
question volontairement naïve quoi c'est
totalement illusoire qu'on puisse
imaginer un jour avoir une enquête sur
les
errances du pouvoir chinois dans la dans
les premières semaines dans la quand le
virus commence à apparaître qu'est-ce
qui a été fait comment ça a été fait etc
c'est totalement illusoire il faut
jamais dire jamais
tout est possible dans les conditions
actuelles disons que c'est extrêmement
difficile parce que quiconque
chercherait à enquêter de façon sérieuse
risquerait effectivement d'être
d'être arrêté et bien évidemment mais
vous savez on a vu
alors là aussi c'est la politique
fiction mais faudrait une inversion de
enfin il faudrait que si Jean Ping perd
son pouvoir pour que éventuellement son
successeur décide de faire un journal
métaux et une enquête est-ce que ça
c'est c'est imaginable aussi bah tout
est là encore je veux dire encore une
fois tout est possible je ne sais pas du
tout ce qu'il en est de la réalité des
rapports de force au sein du Parti
communiste chinois je suis étonné que
tous les membres du comité permanent du
bureau politique c'est-à-dire le sommet
de la hiérarchie soit des gens qui sont
proches de ces jeans et qu'il n'y ait
pas comme toujours la recommandé des
représentants des quatre mers et des
soins continents c'est-à-dire qui soit
d'un peu toutes les les factions ou les
groupes là on l'a pas alors c'est un
vous pouvez dire que c'est une ça prouve
que c'est d'une fille qui est très sûre
de lui qu'il est très fort vous pouvez
aussi dire mais ça prouve que c'est une
fille qui est pas du tout sur de lui et
que il
aucun levier de contrainte c'est à dire
que la Chine pèse contre la communauté
internationale c'est impossible c'est
pas c'est pas possible de contraindre la
chaîne d'accepter une mission
indépendante quand vous êtes membre du
Conseil de sécurité quand vous êtes
membre permanent du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies les Nations Unies
n'ont pas une grande force pour essayer
d'aller contre la volonté d'un membre du
concept d'armement permanent du Conseil
de sécurité et c'est pas seulement la
Chine je veux dire c'est toujours le cas
avec ces membres là-dessus peut-être
Pierre-Antoine Denet vous y réagir non
mais je crois qu'effectivement à partir
du moment où la Chine est l'un des cinq
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité et là tout le loisir de mettre
son veto et puis d'influencer un certain
nombre de pays qui sont un féodés à la
Chine mais je voudrais ajouter que quand
même sur le plan extérieur le vent est
en train de changer vis-à-vis de la
Chine de façon très nette
le temps est fini ou la Chine dictée ces
conditions à toute une série de pays
sur le plan économique était redevable
de près etc aujourd'hui
si zimping même s'il est effectivement
le maître de la Chine en face de lui un
certain nombre de pays qui font plus que
ça interroger sur le bureau réel de tous
ces manœuvres militaires et de
l'expansion chinoise à l'étranger je
voudrais en citer que quelques-uns parce
que ça mériterait un débat trop long
mais bien sûr les États-Unis bon ça dure
depuis
surtout depuis jobidan qui lui a mis les
choses au point que bon il a dit à Sidi
maintenant je serai sur ta route mais à
côté ça il y a le Japon
vous savez le Japon il faut savoir qu'en
1948 sous la dictée d'ailleurs des
Américains après la reddition japonaise
ils ont été contraints d'adopter une
constitution pacifique qui leur interdit
d'intervenir sur un théâtre étranger sur
le plan militaire
et bien c'est en train de changer ça a
changé déjà il y a déjà une bonne
vingtaine d'années mais là c'est
vraiment ce cristalliser parce que là
même l'opinion japonaise est en train de
d'évoluer aujourd'hui la perception de
la Chine est celle d'un ennemi et après
des années et des années des années de
coopération ou le Japon a énormément
donné en considérant la Chine comme un
pays d'étirements
sur sur cette question oui sur deux
points vous vous avez évoqué le cas de
mots longues qui a dû fuir mais il y a
quelqu'un qui a fait à la fois beaucoup
moins et beaucoup plus c'était Johnson
qui était allé une femme qui est allée
prendre des vidéos dans les hôpitaux
pendant la grande crise et cela c'était
terrible elle a été arrêtée elle est
maintenant en prison à Shanghai où elle
a été condamnée je crois pour 4 ans de
prison donc mon anxiété lui c'est si
j'ose dire rien du tout et il y a eu
d'autres cas du même ordre donc essayez
de témoigner en Chine c'est vraiment
extrêmement dangereux un déc chinois il
est soit en prison soit à l'étranger
quoi grosso modo
même s'il est dans sa tête il peut plus
agir et puis il faut pas oublier que il
y a un Taïwan aussi et que la Chine mais
un véto absolu pour l'entrée de Taïwan
dans l'OMS or Taïwan a très bien géré
son épidémie il y a eu très peu de
malade très peu enfin bon ils ont très
bien géré tout ça mais il y a eu des cas
par exemple il y a eu un terrible
tremblement de terre en Inde Taiwan
s'apprêtait à aller porter main fortes
et la Chine est intervenue en
interdisant au volontaire de Taïwan elle
est d'aller travailler là-bas donc même
à l'intérieur de l'OMS qui est une
organisation qui devrait être autonome
et faire ce qu'elle veut la Chine décide
et quand elle dessine que Taïwan ne
vient pas Taïwan ne vient pas alors on
va continuer de d'explorer ce système de
désinformation alors c'est c'est à la
fois intéressant et amusant puisque dans
ce prise de coupe du monde de football
ça craque un petit peu regardez ces deux
réactions sur le réseau social chinois
waybow la première certains assistent en
personne et sans masque au match de la
Coupe du Monde d'autres confinés chez
eux depuis un mois sur site depuis deux
mois sans pouvoir mettre un pied dehors
qui a volé ma vie je ne me prononcerai
pas une autre réaction toujours sur ce
réseau social la Coupe du Monde permet à
la plupart des Chinois de voir la
réalité à l'étranger d'être inquiets
pour l'économie de la patrie et leur
propre jeunesse et puis cette
information il y a une lettre ouverte
demandant si la Chine je cite est sur la
même planète que le Qatar qui a été
diffusé c'était ce mardi sur
l'application de messagerie wechat avant
d'être évidemment très vite censuré
retirer de la plateforme Marie Holtzman
ça provoque quoi ces images de la Coupe
du Monde et essayons de nous nous
projeter là aussi dans les dans les
retours de de l'information d'expérience
de réactions que vous avez
l'information la façon plutôt la
désinformation chinoise fait que la
plupart des Chinois je pense ceux qui
sont pas trop
habiles à aller voir ce qui se passe
ailleurs pensent que la politique est
bon elle est pénible mais elle est plus
ou moins juste là ça a été un choc
terrible parce que tout d'un coup il
voit des gens de tous les pays du monde
personne ne porte masse ils disent mais
il y a vraiment quelque chose qui cloche
donc là c'est un événement qui est aussi
peut provoquer des fêlures à l'intérieur
des convictions chinoises parce que le
système marche sur le mensonge mais à
partir du moment où le mensonge est
dévoilé à ce moment-là l'adhésion de la
population est terminée et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a quelques
années c'est un chinois qui avait parlé
du problème de la
une espèce de crise de Tacite historien
romain donc c'est lui qui avait sorti
cette image et c'était le moment où un
dirigeant un empereur suscite la haine
tout autour de lui qu'il y a plus
personne dans la population qu'il
soutient et si j'ai une ping lui-même au
début son régime avait dit nous devons
éviter plusieurs trappes la trappe de
tussidie et il y avait le piège de
Tacite et là en ce moment on est en
train de s'approcher doucement de ce
piège là dans lequel lui pourrait tomber
le rideau du mensonge qui se déchire
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de en
train de de nous expliquer et donc avec
quels conséquences pour le pouvoir de
chez Jean c'est ça la question il faut
rappeler que le football est extrêmement
important en Chine que tout le monde
regarde la Coupe du monde de football
dans le village le plus reculé du
sudchuan moi j'ai vu des j'étais au
moment de la coupe du monde c'est
complètement délirant tout le monde le
regarde donc effectivement ça fait une
très très forte impression et on n'a pas
encore vu les conséquences de ce qui va
se passer alors évidemment quand le
rideau du mensonge se déchire c'est
quelque chose de positif et ça peut
affaiblir un régime en même temps il
faut pas non plus s'imaginer que le fait
que les gens aient vu que on se balade
sans sans masque au Qatar va
immédiatement faire tomber ce régime je
répète le l'interdiction de s'organiser
le contrôle possible sur l'ensemble de
la population fait que c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile et puis il
faut pas croire non plus que les chinois
sont si naïfs je sais pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que disait Pierre
Antoine tout à l'heure je trouve que les
gens sont souvent pas mal informés sur
beaucoup de choses ils arrivent à
s'informer j'y trouve ça ça circule
quand même je veux dire c'est comme ça
qu'on a vu effectivement quand même des
grèves se répandent et faire un peu
faire un peu boule de neige donc c'est
un peu contradictoire avec ce que je
disais tout à l'heure mais vous savez
aucun système totalitaire n'est parfait
donc le simplement le fait que passer de
la conscience de l'information à
l'action c'est quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus difficile beaucoup plus
compliqué et et c'est risqué Marie
disait turjan elle est elle est en
prison dès que vous dès que vous sortez
que vous voyez sugaronne qui avait
dénoncé aussi dit une fille a été viré
de son poste à six croix et quelqu'un
qui était très proche du pouvoir qui
était Eugène de Tien qui était un Tycoon
dénoncé c'est une fille a été condamné à
18 ans de prison donc il faut bien voir
que même si vous savez les choses etc le
fait de passer du savoir à l'action
c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus difficile beaucoup de gens sont
informés mais comment faire comment
faire pour pouvoir alors ce qui ce qui
est possible la manière dont ça se passe
dans ce genre de régime des transitions
c'est que vous avez une partie de des
élites de l'intérieur du parti qui
s'entend le mécontentement serait se
répandre essaye de profiter de ce
mécontentement pour abattre c'est pour
au moins affaiblir le rival le seul
problème c'est que la le 20e Congrès a
donné un site INPI une un contrôle sur
l'ensemble du parti et du 20e congrès
c'est l'aboutissement de 10 ans de purge
du parti qui ont été extrêmement
violents 5 millions de membres de cadres
du parti ont été exclus et parfois et
très souvent condamné 55 membres
au-dessus du niveau du comité central
c'est-à-dire il y a combien de
d'adhérents
400 millions c'est pour ça mais si vous
voulez donc l'existence d'une comme on a
eu au moment des années dans les années
80 d'une faction qui chercherait à
profiter de ce à profiter ou utiliser à
ce joindre à se mécontentement pour
essayer de faire relâcher les contrôles
c'est quelque chose qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui nous ne connaissons pas de
factions qui soient véritablement
organisée alors il y a beaucoup de
mécontentement à l'intérieur du parti il
faut pas croire je parlais tout à
l'heure de de l'hésitation des gens à
mettre en oeuvre même la politique de
zéro covid de relâchement de la
politique de relâchement sur le covid
parce que les gens n'osent pas prendre
donc il n'y a pas d'initiative c'est
très mauvais aussi pour l'économie et
c'est très mauvais pour le parti dans un
sens mais d'un autre côté c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui fait que
une opposition aura beaucoup de mal à se
structure est-ce qu'on peut comparer la
Chine à la Corée du Nord
alors on peut tout comparer mais enfin
on est dans les occidentaux on parle
très peu de dictatures pour la Chine
pourquoi
je veux dire c'est un marché on y
investit on parle d'une on parle là de
Foxton qui est quand même la plus grande
usine de fabrication de de d'iPhone du
monde et puis autrement vous savez il y
a une chose on dit très souvent il faut
pas vous savez que les Chinois il faut
faire très attention et ils sont il faut
pas leur faire perdre la face donc ils
ont un très grand concept de la phase
complètement absurde mais enfin c'est
comme ça en même temps c'est vrai que la
Chine est un pays si vous parlez par
exemple de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique comment vous
faites sur la Chine vous êtes obligé
d'être obligé de parler avec la Chine
plus on a quand même eu un certain
nombre de déclarations depuis les des
deux dernières années notamment sur ce
qui se passe au Cynthia vous avez
beaucoup de gouvernement qui ont des
prépositions sur la manière dont la
Chine se comporte
vous savez par rapport à ce qui se
passait il y a il y a 10 ans il y a un
certain nombre de progrès je vais vous
donner la parole Marvel semaine mais je
propose à Jérémy de nous rejoindre tout
de suite Jérémy Hansmann sur ce plateau
justement pour voir les conséquences de
cette politique bonsoir Jérémy zero
covid sur le commerce international oui
bien première conséquence les prix du
pétrole ont plongé cette semaine
notamment à cause des craintes autour de
l'augmentation de cas positifs en Chine
par exemple le prix du baril de Brent de
la Mer du Nord a perdu plus de 3% comme
le baril américain de West Texas
intermédiate les restrictions sanitaires
font même craindre un essoufflement de
la demande en pétrole dont la Chine est
le premier importateur au monde surtout
la politique zéro covid fait peur aux
entreprises européennes installées en
Chine selon une enquête annuelle de la
Chambre de commerce de l'Union
européenne à Pékin et bien 23% de ces
entreprises envisagent des
investissements hors du pays un
pourcentage au plus haut depuis 10 ans
et puis la question des pénuries quels
sont les principaux produits concernés
oui ben on peut déjà citer les produits
high tech en particulier l'entreprise
Apple a déjà annoncé qu'elle ne pourra
pas livrer autant de nouveaux iPhone 14
que prévu pour Noël en raison des
baisses d'activité dans ces usines
chinoises celle de zenzu par exemple
assemblent 60% du total de ce modèle
autre conséquence intéressante c'est la
pénurie de certains médicaments comme
l'amoxicilline il s'agit de
l'antibiotique le plus prescrit en
France pour soigner notamment la
sinusite l'otite ou encore l'angine et
bien des ruptures de stock sont prévues
jusqu'en mars à cause notamment de
difficultés sur les lignes de production
car vous le savez la concentration de la
production de la matière première en
Chine et en Inde fragilisent la ligne
d'appro environnement c'est ce que dit
en tout cas l'Observatoire de la
transparence dans les politiques du
médicament et la situation pourrait
encore se détériorer dans les prochains
mois le Fond Monétaire International le
FMI prévoit lui l'arrêt progressif de la
politique zéro covid chinoise seulement
au second semestre 2023 merci Jérémy
pour toutes ces informations
Pierre-Antoine Denet vous l'avez évoqué
mais rapidement tout à l'heure je veux
bien qu'on développe il nous reste à peu
près 7 minutes dans ce dans ce premier
débat c'est quoi c'est un
appauvrissement des Chinois auxquels on
assiste en ce moment vous savez en fait
le Parti communiste chinois il a il n'a
pas de légitimité la première il l'a en
partie économique ce qu'en 2020 le parti
connu chinois a proclamé avec en phase
que pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la Chine plus personne ne
mourrait de faim bon certes on passait
sous le silence le grand bon en avant il
y a eu au moins 40 millions de morts de
fin voilà
mais bon il y avait une part de vérité
la deuxième légitimité c'est entre
guillemets récupérer Taïwan ou
faire en sorte que ta voix ne revienne
dans le giron chinois ça c'est une autre
affaire mais sur le plan économique
je pense que là effectivement il y a un
sujet à inquiétude pour les Chinois
parce que bon on sait il y a les Ultra
riches et les ultrasons parce que même
s'il mange à leur faim il reste quand
même des centaines de millions de
Chinois qui sont sur le bord de la route
avec ce chômage qui monte avec cette je
dirais pas décroissance parce qu'on en
est pas là mais ralentissement très
sérieux de la croissance c'est tout
l'environnement économique intérieur à
la Chine qui est en train de changer et
là je pense qu'il y a des conséquences
qui sont encore difficiles à appréhender
parce que c'est sur le moyen terme mais
qui peuvent être colossales Mario juste
pour bien comprendre parce que nous on
voit ça avec notre confinement
européen ou français pour les salariés
chinois qui sont confinés et ils sont
payés ils sont pas payés
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui soit à
travailler de façon temporaire enfin ils
avaient des petites Jobs ils pouvaient
donner des cours enfin où ils étaient
livreurs tout d'un coup ils sont
confinés vous imaginez bien qu'il y a
pas un patron qui est là pour leur
envoyer leur salaire tous les mois il y
a pas de quoi qu'il en coûte à la
chinoise
ça c'est sûr oh les jeunes qui avaient
un peu commencé leur vie ce sont
endettés pour acheter des appartements
et là on a eu des des scènes de
désespoir y compris des suicides parce
que d'un côté ils avaient plus de quoi
manger de l'autre côté ils avaient plus
de quoi payer la banque et la banque
leur disait ben dans ce cas là on saisit
votre appartement c'est c'est des
situations invraisemblables et je
voudrais revenir à votre question sur la
Corée du Nord en fait c'est une blague
chinoise qui date d'il y a je sais pas
cinq six ans qui disait chez nous il y a
la Corée du Sud il y a la Corée du Nord
et nous on est la Corée de l'Ouest et
ils le voyait venir avec chidin il
disait si Jean Ping est en train de nous
faire ressembler à la Corée du Nord mais
inversement la Corée du Nord qui est
régime absolument invraisemblable quoi
n'aurait jamais tenu sans le soutien
permanent discret est un site de la
Chine pour la Corée du Nord pour éviter
l'arrivée d'une démocratie bruyante
décomplexé de la Corée du Sud qui en
plus un très grand soft power et tout et
qui amuse aussi les Chinois donc tout ça
on voit bien le rôle de chez Jean Ping à
l'heure actuelle et l'inquiétude de gens
comme sihin qui est une femme qui s'est
exilée et qui est très très fine
observatif sur la Chine elle dit c'est
très grave pour les Chinois parce que
petit à petit on est en train de les
desservoler desservéler c'est
relativement facile mais les refaire
penser correctement c'est très difficile
et moi je trouve que on voit ça en
Russie beaucoup de Russes ont été
desservés et on voit bien maintenant
qu'ils sont prêts à croire toutes les
stupidités que peut dire Poutine alors
qu'est-ce que ça va donner c'est très
inquiétant on l'a dit il petit
obstination du président chinois à
maintenir cette stratégie zéro covid il
l'avait notamment exprimé lors de son
discours d'ouverture de ce 20e congrès
dont on parlait le Congrès du Parti
communiste
de covid-19 nous nous efforçons de
donner la priorité à la population et
aux vies humaines d'adhérer à une
politique inébranlable de zéro covid
dynamique de mener une guerre populaire
une guerre totale et une guerre de
blocus pour combattre la pandémie de
protéger au plus haut point la sécurité
et la santé du peuple nous avons atteint
des résultats positifs significatifs en
coordonnant la prévention et le contrôle
de l'épidémie avec le développement
économique et social
c'est intéressant parce qu'on pourrait
prendre toutes les phrases de cette
citation de oxygène ping et vous avez
démontré que c'était faux depuis le
début de ce débat mais je voudrais
terminer
Jean-Philippe déjà je suis une question
liée à l'économie en fait et est-ce que
l'affaiblissement économique vous avez
dit qu'il y a des entreprises
internationales qui sont Jérémy le
rappeler qui sont en train de de changer
de prestataire quoi qui vont vers
peut-être la Turquie d'autres pays et
qui quittent la Chine est-ce que ça ça
peut faire changer d'avis le pouvoir
chinois c'est le risque économique
à court terme difficilement je pense que
c'est d'une Ping a décidé d'appuyer son
pouvoir sur une légitimité légitimité
sur la politique c'est à dire que la
politique est au poste de commande et
c'est ce qui est le plus important donc
il faut éviter quelques menaces que ce
soit alors tant que c'est on n'est pas
arrivé à une situation absolument
dramatique qui provoquerait des émeutes
partout je crois qu'il y aura pas de
retrait là-dessus mais évidemment
ça se reprend donc je veux dire et puis
vous savez les feuilles il fait quand
même aussi regarder un peu le
comportement de multinationales oui ils
partent mais regardez Foxton regardez
regardez un peu il passe il part pas
tous apple continue à faire ses iPhone
en Chine donc c'est moins et j'ai pas le
seul enfin tout le monde
oui enfin sauf que les leurs principales
usine est là-bas ils disent qu'ils vont
quitter la chute oui ils ont commencé un
petit burn-out
mais ça c'est déjà fait et à chaque fois
ils sont revenus en Chine je crois quand
même que c'est pas c'est pas si évident
d'autre part je pense qu'effectivement
au bout d'un moment ce sera une question
parce que comme nous disait justement
Pierre-Antoine une partie de la
légitimité du parti était sur
l'augmentation du 10 maux de vie s'il y
a une baisse dramatique du niveau de vie
il y aura du mécontentement la question
qui se pose toujours en Chine et qu'il
faut toujours regarder c'est est-ce que
mes enfants vivront mieux que moi ou
vivront moins bien
parce que les gens sont prêts à se
sacrifier entièrement si leurs enfants
vivent plus on a vu ça dans les années
80 les les gens qui venaient de la
campagne et qui se travaillaient 12
heures par jour 15 heures par jour parce
que leurs enfants minthiens demain ça
ira mieux et ben aussi aujourd'hui on se
dit demain ce sera pire alors là ils
peuvent faire très attention ils sont
vraiment menacés et je crois que ils y
sont relativement attentifs dans une
certaine mesure merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vais rappeler Pierre-Antoine donnait le
titre de votre livre le dossier chinois
portrait d'un pays au bord de la Bible
publié aux éditions du Cherche